[Música]
con un de cerca de 24 billones de
dólares Estados Unidos de lejos la
economía más importante de todo el mundo
la economía norteamericana queridos
amigos es tan grande que por sí mismo
supone casi una cuarta parte de todo el
pib mundial los norteamericanos devoran
más productos que nadie Prácticamente
todo el mundo quiere comerciar con ellos
es con mucha diferencia el mercado más
importante y lucrativo que podamos
encontrar ningún otro país se acerca a
la capacidad económica de esta
superpotencia ahora bien como de abierto
está realmente El Tío Sam en el comercio
mundial Qué papel juega el comercio
internacional en la economía
norteamericana conocéis la última
apuesta de la Administración biden para
integrar la economía norteamericana con
gran parte de América Latina pues
queridos amigos amigas En este vídeo
vamos a responder a todas estas
cuestiones Pero antes antes tenemos que
saber exactamente de qué va toda esta
historia arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
los seres humanos llevamos milenios
comerciando por no decir que lo hemos
hecho durante toda nuestra historia sin
embargo la idea de un mundo integrado
por redes comerciales y cadenas de
producción internacionales repartidas
por aquí y por allá Es algo muchísimo
más reciente algo que a gran escala
lleva con nosotros apenas unas pocas
décadas por ejemplo los primeros
acuerdos de libre comercio entre países
datan de 1860 y tuvieron como
protagonista como no al imperio
británico con la firma del tratado
coptent chevalier con Francia en enero
de ese mismo año décadas después el
tratado de Versalles de 1919 uno de los
primeros documentos multilaterales que
consideró el intercambio comercial entre
países como un eje clave para la
prosperidad global sin embargo la
Segunda Guerra Mundial y la Guerra Fría
marcaron las décadas siguientes por
ejemplo en su enfrentamiento con la
unión soviética los Estados Unidos
promovieron El libre comercio pero al
mismo tiempo también mantuvieron muchas
medidas proteccionistas sobre sectores
que consideraban estratégicos y lo
cierto es que internacional se centraron
sobre todo en cuestiones de seguridad de
esta forma la gran explosión del
comercio mundial no llegaría hasta los
años 90 y principios del siglo XXI un
proceso que sorprendentemente no fue
liderado claramente por Estados Unidos
atentos
[Música]
deislacionismo a la rivalidad como Moscú
queridos amigos existe un amplio
consenso acerca de Estados Unidos una
buena parte de su enorme éxito a la hora
de explotar su inmenso potencial
económico y político tuvo lugar Gracias
a su particular situación geopolítica y
sabéis que esta es una interpretación
que viene de lejos fijaos no encontrando
Estados Unidos en el exterior enemigo
alguno que pueda amenazarlo seriamente
el pueblo americano está siempre ocupado
en la tarea de mejorar su situación
Alexis de toque Bill la democracia en
América en
1835-1840 la peculiar seguridad de la
geografía americana dio a Estados Unidos
una seguridad económica que le permitió
concentrarse en las artes de la paz
mientras a otras naciones satisfacer su
gusto por la guerra David Potter la
realidad es que el Tío Sam creció en un
clima libre de grandes conflictos
bélicos Y sí lo sé obviamente la guerra
civil y algunos roces militares
relativamente menores como la guerra con
México pues eventualmente le hicieron
agitar sus armas pero evidentemente no
es algo comparable a los constantes
conflictos que durante siglos pues
inundaron la historia de la vieja Europa
que os voy a contar además Estados
Unidos Pues tampoco sufrió nunca las
consecuencias de tener al mando a
grandes atrapas más preocupados por
extraer rentas para su bolsillo que por
el desempeño económico del país y qué
queréis que os diga eso eso se nota
en cualquier caso la cuestión es que
durante años y años los estadounidenses
hicieron crecer su economía y
desarrollaron un enorme y prex pero
mercado interno que sin embargo se
mantuvo en cierta forma alejado del
resto del mundo hasta que de una forma u
otra el mundo llegó hasta ellos es lo
que habitualmente se conoce como el
aislacionismo norteamericano una isla
accionismo tanto político como económico
pero queréis un ejemplo concreto de lo
ponía esta vocación pues fijaos Estados
Unidos evitó a toda Costa unirse a la
Sociedad De Naciones la precursora de la
ONU a pesar de que su propio presidente
buró Wilson había sido uno de sus
grandes promotores digamos que por
aquella época los Estados Unidos pues no
estaban particularmente interesados en
el resto del mundo e incluso recordad
todo lo que les costó meterse de lleno
en la Segunda Guerra Mundial pero claro
justo fue en esa época cuando se produjo
un punto de inflexión que cambiaría la
historia del mundo cuando las fuerzas
japonesas bombardearon de repente
cambiaron la perspectiva norteamericana
para siempre a partir de ese momento el
país de las barras y las estrellas nunca
jamás volvería a mirar para otro lado
pero vale vale lo sé a ver Enrique qué
demonios tiene que ver todo esto de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial con el tema de
este vídeo
[Música]
pues veréis la cuestión es que en 1941
en la conocida carta del Atlántico
acordada tras una reunión secreta entre
Churchill y Roosevelt Y estos dos países
se fijaron exactamente esta meta
cláusula 4 extender a todos los estados
pequeños grandes victoriosos o vencidos
la posibilidad de acceso a condiciones
de igualdad al comercio y a las materias
primas mundiales que son necesarias para
su prosperidad económica carta del
Atlántico 14 de agosto de 1941 de esta
forma cuando terminó la guerra y se
levantó el telón de acero Washington
cayó en una especie de periodo de pacto
Manía Es decir para entendernos una
especie de obsesión casi compulsiva por
alcanzar nuevos acuerdos con otros
países había que hacer amigos a toda
Costa hablamos de la época del Plan
Marshall o la creación de la propia ota
Es lógico que Estados Unidos haga todo
lo que está a su alcance para contribuir
al retorno de la salud económica normal
en el mundo sin la cual no puede haber
estabilidad política ni segura los
gobiernos partidos políticos o grupos
que busquen perpetuar la miseria humana
con el fin de beneficiarse políticamente
o de otra manera encontrarán la
oposición de los Estados Unidos discurso
del secretario de estado George Marshall
el 5 de junio de 1947 la prioridad
Entonces era absolutamente Clara todas
las herramientas de cooperación
económica formaban parte de los
instrumentos que Estados Unidos podía
nuclear en su particular Cruzada contra
la unión soviética y este era Quizás El
único problema digamos que la obsesión
norteamericana se centraba en alcanzar
acuerdos que le dieran ventaja
geopolítica frente a Moscú y la amenaza
soviética es decir que el comercio era
Por así decirlo un instrumento de lucha
pero no Un fin en sí mismo pero amigos
amigas aún así se lograron avances muy
importantes
en 1947 la ciudad de Ginebra fuese de
múltiples reuniones multilaterales donde
las diferentes potencias trataron de
concretar un nuevo tratado que daría
lugar al gas el acuerdo general sobre
aranceles aduaneros y Comercio en esta
Cumbre los debates más crispados se
dieron entre Londres y Washington el
viejo hegemon no confiaba en una rápida
apertura de los mercados mientras que
Estados Unidos hizo debutar su
incuestionable liderazgo occidental
acelerando las reformas bastante más de
lo que esperaban sus propios socios
bajos aranceles reglas comunes movilidad
de las mercancías y casi total libertad
de cambio y claro ya os podéis hacer una
idea si estas son cosas difíciles de
concretar hoy en día imaginaos en los
años 50 cuando además todavía reinaba
una enorme desconfianza hacia el recién
creado orden internacional Así que sí el
gat se aprobó Pero no logró forzar a las
potencias occidentales a reducir sus
aranceles sino que esto se dejó A
discreción de los diferentes gobiernos
[Música]
además Poco después en 1948 tuvo lugar
la conferencia de las Naciones Unidas
sobre el comercio y el empleo en la
Habana y el 24 de marzo de ese mismo año
53 estados occidentales firmaron una
carta procurando la creación de la
conocida como organización Internacional
del comercio sin embargo queridos amigos
justo aquí reapareció con fuerza El
fantasma de leisesionismo estadounidense
en el año 1950 el presidente truman
anunció que no presentaría la carta de
La Habana Ya que en el senado la mayoría
de los legisladores se oponían
frontalmente a formar parte de esta
organización por supuesto En aquel
momento si los Estados Unidos se
quedaban fuera eso significaba que la
propuesta automáticamente quedaba
cancelada de esa forma el prematuro
sueño de tener una organización
comercial internacional llegó a su fin
las negociaciones y la promoción del
comercio se llevaría a cabo en
diferentes rondas del gato El problema
es que este fue un gran acuerdo con
muchas muchísimas limitaciones el
tratado tenía poco poder para hacer
cumplir las normas y estaba muy limitado
a la hora de resolver las disputas y
solo alcanzaba al mercado de bienes no a
los servicios ni a la propiedad
intelectual ni tampoco a la inversión
extranjera digamos que era una especie
de acuerdo de mínimo y luego a la hora
de la verdad pues muchos países ni
siquiera respetaban además a medida que
más y más países se incorporaban a este
acuerdo las diferentes negociaciones Se
volvieron interminables con todo a
medida que la Guerra Fría empezó a
descongelarse las viejas ideas de la
integración volvieron a ganar peso en
Estados Unidos y con ello en todo
occidente la caída del muro supuso todo
un punto de inflexión un antes y un
después
[Música]
la del muro y uni económica
entre 1947 y 1990 tuvieron lugar cerca
de ocho rondas de negociaciones
enmarcadas en el acuerdo hogar en estas
rondas los estados miembros se reunían
para acordar nuevas medidas para
facilitar el comercio exterior El
problema es que estas negociaciones eran
larguísimas en promedio para que os
hagáis una idea cada ronda duraba 29
meses sí sí me habéis escuchado bien y
no nos hemos equivocado de media cada
vez que se quería reducir alguna Barrera
comercial se tiraban negociando más de
dos años y claro así pues cuesta mucho
con todo avances lo que se dice avances
sí que se lograron por ejemplo la ronda
iniciada en Suiza en mayo del 64
conocida como La Ronda Kennedy supuso un
importante salto adelante se redujeron a
la mitad los aranceles de muchas
materias primas y se eliminaron un
montón de Barreras No arancelarias claro
que la siguiente ronda serían bastante
distintas mucho más pantanosas con
avances más o menos constantes pero
frecuentemente excesivamente tímidos
Esto fue así hasta que en septiembre de
1986 comenzó la octava ronda en Uruguay
queridos amigos amigas este proceso de
negociaciones duraría nada más y nada
menos que 87 meses más de 7 años en los
que se produjeron dos hechos clave la
caída del muro de Berlín y la disolución
de la unión soviética cuando empezó la
ronda en Uruguay Ronald Reagan era el
inquilino de la Casa Blanca pero otras
meses y meses y meses de negociaciones
en Montevideo Ginebra Bruselas
Washington DC y Tokio en el gobierno
norteamericano cambió dos veces de mano
primero a Bush padre y luego a bill
Clinton Eso sí en 1993 por fin de una
vez por todas las naciones participantes
alcanzaron un acuerdo y no hablamos de
un acuerdo cualquiera con el fin de la
Guerra Fría queridos amigos había
surgido un mundo nuevo un mundo que
necesitaba un nuevo sistema de
cooperación comercial y de esta forma es
como resurgió con éxito la idea de crear
una organización multilateral un
organismo para gobernar el comercio
mundial atentos
[Música]
Clinton la MC y la integración que no
fue
el día 15 de abril de 1994 fue un día
histórico para la economía mundial ese
día 123 países Incluyendo los propios
Estados Unidos firmaron el acuerdo de
marrakech un acuerdo que estableció la
creación de la Organización Mundial del
Comercio y queridos amigos amigas este
fue de lejos El despegue definitivo de
la integración económica mundial El
Salto definitivo de la globalización y
la construcción del mundo que hoy todos
conocemos tal y como podéis ver a partir
de ese momento Los acuerdos comerciales
se multiplicaron antes semejante
escenario la presidencia de Bill Clinton
apostó por a fondo con esta nueva
organización y lo cierto Es que
consiguieron algunos hitos tan
importantes como la entrada de la
mismísima República popular china en
este organismo sin embargo Y esto es lo
más curioso de todo los esfuerzos de
Washington se centraron particularmente
en el resto del mundo es decir en la
casa blanca aún no había ninguna
catarata de nuevos tratados de libre
comercio que Estados Unidos estuviera
pensando firmar con un mundo que estaba
abandonando el socialismo a toda
velocidad para echarse en brazos del
comercio el capitalismo y la
globalización pensad que por aquel
entonces el único tratado relevante
material de libre comercio que tenía
Estados Unidos era un acuerdo de 1988
con Canadá un acuerdo que en el 94
Clinton convertiría con la inclusión de
México en el tratado de libre comercio
de América del Norte El archiconocido
nafta este fue el primer gran paso que
los Estados Unidos dieron para sumarse a
la Nueva Ola en favor del comercio libre
que se extendía por todo el planeta
[Música]
claro que el entusiasmo norteamericano
tardaría todavía mucho en dar resultados
no fue hasta el año 2004 cuando Estados
Unidos escribió nuevos acuerdos de libre
comercio con chile Australia Jordania
Singapur la República Dominicana y
Centroamérica el entonces presidente
George Walker Bush era un firme
partidario de extender y ampliar esta
política sin embargo en el 2005 se
produjo un portazo terriblemente
doloroso que dejaría muchas secuelas en
la casa blanca que de que estamos
hablando pues prestas mucha pero que
muchísima atención
[Música]
una superpotencia rechazada por sus
vecinos
en noviembre de 2003 34 países
Prácticamente todo el continente
americano al completo se reunieron en
Miami para conocer un plan ideado por la
Casa Blanca un plan sin precedentes que
buscaba extender el tratado de libre
comercio de América del Norte entre
Canadá México y los Estados Unidos a
toda la región creando así la conocida
como área de libre comercio de las
Américas el Alka el acuerdo tenía que
cerrarse en un plazo de dos años pero
justo en 2005 en la cuarta cumbre de las
Américas que se realizó en Argentina
George Bush se dio de frente con la ola
roja que por aquel momento Bueno al
igual que ocurre en nuestros días y casi
que da igual cuando veas este vídeo
atravesaba la región mar del plata está
la tumba del alca
[Aplausos]
alca alca al [__]
nuestros pobres nuestros excluidos
nuestros países nuestra democracia ya no
soportan más que sigamos hablando en voz
baja es fundamental hablar con mucho
respeto y en voz alta para construir un
sistema que nos vuelva a contener a
todos en un marco de igualdad y nos
vuelva a devolver la esperanza y la
posibilidad de construir obviamente un
mundo distinto el alcano fue una demanda
de América Latina fue una oferta de
Washington que increíblemente fue
rechazada lo que supuso una de las
jornadas más humillantes para la
política exterior norteamericana de las
últimas décadas
[Música]
la idea el plan la gran apuesta del
despacho aval había sido maltratada
pública y notoriamente por los grandes
referentes socialistas de la época al
finalizar aquella Cumbre queridos amigos
bus se fue de Argentina dando por
finalizada a la aventura de la
integración comercial irónicamente esta
vez era el mundo en este caso
latinoamérica el que le decía no a los
Estados Unidos lo por supuesto supuso
rechazar una oportunidad de oro para
integrar esta región con la mayor
economía de todo el planeta Ver para
creer
exceso
fue una apuesta fallida una apuesta que
supuso otro punto de inflexión más para
Estados Unidos atentos
[Música]
pozalca todo mucho más medido
la potencia norteamericana había
comenzado su gran apertura comercial con
sus vecinos más próximos México y Canadá
luego quiso llevar esta apuesta a todo
el continente americano pero el portazo
al alca hizo que Washington se cansará
de toda esta historia muy pronto
actualmente Estos son tan solo los 19
tratados de libre comercio de Estados
Unidos que están en vigor
Y eso eso no es todo si además de los
acuerdos de libre comercio consideramos
otros acuerdos menores podemos comprobar
como la apertura del gigante
norteamericano es mucho más limitada
Pero cómo demonios es posible que países
como Perú Turquía China o incluso
Ucrania hayan suscrito más acuerdos
comerciales que los mismísimos Estados
Unidos realmente estamos hablando de una
economía tan cerrada pues lo cierto Es
que aquí hay que hacer varios matices
Empezando por este
[Música]
Estados Unidos sigue realizando la mayor
parte de sus intercambios comerciales
bajo la cláusula de la nación más
favorecida una cláusula de la omc que
garantiza que el mejor trato que un país
miembro le da otro miembro tiene que
aplicar se a todos excepto en los casos
de acuerdos de libre comercio de esta
forma Estados Unidos fija sus aranceles
y luego los aplica de forma general Esto
hace que por ejemplo en 2021 el 49,9% de
las importaciones de los Estados Unidos
ingresarán libres de aranceles el 14,8%
de las importaciones se beneficiaron de
reducciones arancelarias y el 0,9% se
benefició de preferencias unilaterales
en favor de los países más pobres
En otras palabras no es que Estados
Unidos haya cerrado al mundo ni
renunciado a los beneficios del comercio
sino que más bien ha utilizado hasta la
saciedad la normativa de la vc materia
de aranceles por ejemplo negociando y
Estableciendo el nivel de aranceles para
cada tipo de producto esto le ha dado a
Washington un control mucho más político
en la gestión del comercio y es
exactamente lo que explica noticias como
estas junio de 2022 la crisis millonaria
de la aceituna negra española por el
arancel de Estados Unidos 30 de octubre
de 2021 la ue y Estados Unidos
desactivan su guerra arancelaria sobre
el acero y el aluminio Eso sí todo hay
que decirlo con carácter general Estados
Unidos aplica una tarifa aduanera que
está entre las más bajas de todo el
mundo hablamos de un promedio de apenas
el 3,5
pero sea como sea en la última época
Washington sí que estuvo trabajando en
la posible creación de una zona de libre
comercio entre Estados Unidos
evidentemente hubo un acuerdo de
asociación transpacífico y una utópica
asociación transatlántica de comercio de
inversión con la propia Unión Europea
sin embargo la llegada de Donald Trump a
la casa blanca hizo que todos estos
esfuerzos de la Administración Obama
quedarán en saco roto Claro que ahora
esa posición podría volver a cambiar y
podría hacerlo además en América Latina
habéis oído hablar de la última apuesta
de la Administración biden en materia de
comercio estamos acaso ante un nuevo
desembarco gringo en América Latina pues
atentos
[Aplausos]
calienta para la prosperidad económica
en las Américas arca 2.0
en junio del 2022 anunció la creación de
la alianza para la prosperidad económica
en las Américas una iniciativa que
comienza con pintar una especie de alca
más moderado pero encaminado a construir
tarde o temprano una nueva alianza
estrecha y con una fuerte apuesta
comercial Eso sí entre amigos
relativamente cercanos este diálogo
reúne la fuerza el Ingenio y la
diversidad de una región increíblemente
dinámica somos el 90% del pib del
hemisferio occidental casi dos tercios
de su población no hay nada que no
podamos hacer juntos Anthony blinken
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
todavía se conoce en pocos detalles pero
por el momento la Casa Blanca ha dejado
muy claro que esta iniciativa nace para
impulsar el comercio la inversión y la
aplicación de normativas comunes entre
los países que forman parte de esta
nueva iniciativa entre otras cosas es
una de las fórmulas con las que la
administración va a Irene aspira a
reducir el peso de China cómo pues
impulsando las cadenas de producción
regionales el que ya os hemos hablado
aquí en visual
[Música]
en cualquier caso si algo está claro es
que puede ser una oportunidad de oro una
más para que latinoamérica pueda darte
una vez por todas un enorme salto hacia
adelante como pues y sus dirigentes son
espabilados aprovechándose del mayor
mercado de consumo y inversión de todo
el planeta en cualquier caso queridos
amigos no me negaréis que tiene cierta
gracia que Estados Unidos la gran
potencia capitalista que ganó la Guerra
Fría no haya conseguido liberar el
sistema de comercio mundial Pero en fin
llegado hasta aquí turno para ti crees
que Estados Unidos tendría que ser mucho
más ambicioso con su política comercial
sería esto algo bueno o algo malo Qué
papel llegará a jugar la alianza para la
prosperidad económica en las Américas
déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y hablamos debate y ahora si
este vídeo se ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de like y
suscribiros si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho una vez más Muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]